today the mat wall show the law of
banning child mutilation has now been
passed by the Tennessee legislature we
are fighting back and we are winning
meanwhile craze drag queens and trans
activists as they lose are getting more
desperate are now threatening violence
and claiming that they're victims of
genocide these are the scare tactics
that have worked in the past but no
longer also video Services of HHS
secretary Rachel Levine demanding that
he be not only tolerated but celebrated
and says that explicitly Donald Trump
visits East Palestine P budajig follows
behind them a day later the bind
administration's most notorious luggage
Thief has apparently been on the prowl
for much longer than we thought finally
a far left race activist finds out to
her horror that she is descended from a
pilgrim on the Mayflower how quickly
does the oppressed become the oppressor
all of that and more today on the Matt
Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
of people will die someday 100 according
to a recent poll 62 of Americans who
think about their own death a lot a lot
of the time still don't have a will and
that's kind of like being afraid of
drowning but refusing to wear a life
jacket or to learn how to swim creating
a will is one of the most important
things you could do to ensure your
belongings and your loved ones are taken
care of after you pass away my partners
at Epic will can help you set up a will
today and they can do it all that for
just 119 in as little as five minutes
epic will help you create your last will
and testament your living will even
Health Care power of attorney go to
epicworld.com Walsh to get my discount
code and save an extra 10 on your
complete will package with epic wheels
easy to use template all you got to do
is fill in the blanks and uh and and in
order to do that you have to go to
epicwill.com Walsh to save 10 on Epic
Wheels complete will package that's
epicwell.com Welsh
today House Bill one called the
protecting children from gender
mutilation act finally passed the
Tennessee House of Representatives it's
a legislation that will ban doctors from
giving puberty blockers and cross-sex
hormones to children or performing
gender quote-unquote gender reassignment
surgeries on children this law which
will soon be signed by the governor and
then officially enacted will actively
save kids from one of the most Sinister
forms of child abuse the world has ever
known
laws just like it are being passed all
across the country which means not only
the countless children will be protected
from this evil but also that the
cultural tide is turning in a very real
and measurable way and that's not
something that happens by accident now
it's true as the saying goes the culture
is Upstream from politics and so this
bill in Tennessee and others around the
country are in large part of their
response to cultural changes and those
cultural changes are not incidental but
rather the direct result of work that
has been done by many people in many
places including us here of course at
the daily wire
as for myself you know that I've been
fighting against gender ideology for
many years yet for much of that time
fighting
like it does so often for me for for
much of that time fighting men simply
you know talking about it and there is
value in talking about things of course
but our problem as conservatives is that
too often we just leave it there we talk
and talk and talk and we're in the
talking phase the whole time and when
that doesn't work we talk some more it
feels fruitless after a while and it is
if there's no escalation no next phase
talk is impotent if it isn't coupled
with action and so a couple years ago I
decided it was time for action and short
time later we published Johnny The
Walrus you know we've had a lot of fun
with the very hilarious fact that I'm a
best-selling LGBT children's author and
the book itself is funny and meant to be
but it also has a serious purpose it's
an actual children's book meant for
children
um which has now been read by and too
many children which is supposed to be in
antidote to the gender ideology
indoctrination that pervades the
children's section in nearly every
bookstore in America
uh the book would go on to sell over 100
000 copies in a few months uh we were
not the first conservatives to publish a
children's book with a quote-unquote
conservative outlook on a current issue
but ours was certainly
um at least among the most successful in
that category
now when the book was published we had
already begun filming what is a woman
and in January of 2022 though the movie
wasn't complete yet we had uh filmed
enough to be sure that we had something
significant on our hands and that's when
I announced publicly that 2022 would be
the year when we wage an all-out assault
on gender ideology and I promised that
we would be dealing at some major blows
that year and I wanted to call the shot
so that people would know that this is
all part of a plan wanted our allies to
know that I want our enemies to know
that that month my episode of Dr Phil
was released and went viral a few months
later when his woman came out took the
country by storm and then in the fall
with all the momentum we had built up we
set out to expose and shut down
Vanderbilt's child mutilation Clinic a
few weeks after that report Clinic was
shut down we're holding a rally in the
state capitol uh thousands of people
were there several lawmakers attended
the rally announced that they would work
on legislation to ban the practice in
Tennessee then this week that bill
passed and now awaits the governor's
signature while similar bills work their
way through the legislatures and many
other states or in some cases have now
been passed
now
lots of people on the right talk about
fighting and call themselves Fighters
but when I say that we're fighting here
at the daily wire this is what I mean
and of course none of this is possible
without our members the films the books
the investigative work the rallies
everything else
can't do any of that or achieve any of
the victories without people who support
us and support our work and by
supporting it contribute to it
so I use the word we when I talk about
all these things because this truly is a
we operation like I said already I was
talking about this for many years but
only talking I can talk on my own I
don't need anybody else for that you
know I could just I can talk all day but
uh I needed the daily wire and all of
you to actually do all of these things
that's why your membership is so
important
and this work becomes all the more
important as the other side continues
its own escalation
so for example there's another bill soon
to be passed here in Tennessee which
would outlaw sexual performances for
children this would have the effect of
primarily Banning family quote-unquote
family-friendly drag shows and the
reason that I say it would primarily ban
those is that drag queens are the
primary ones who are most eager and
insistent on performing in front of kids
which is all the more reason
um so it's it's a little bit like if I
said that uh you know stealing is
illegal and that primarily affects
kleptomaniacs well it's not a bill that
says only kleptomaniacs can't steal but
if you have a compulsion to steal then
uh you know in a in a certain way you
might say that you're more affected by
that bill but that's because of you
that's a you problem it's your own fault
uh and it's the same thing here
so the drag queens who feel targeted by
a bill that won't let them sexualize
children well if it targets you that's
only because you have this apparently by
your own confession this uh special uh
compulsion to engage in that kind of
behavior
which is all the more reason why you
shouldn't be allowed to
but a leftist activist and drag queen it
goes by the name Bella dubal addressed
the crowd here in Tennessee a few days
ago
and uh and he he had his own suggestion
for how the opponents of this bill ought
to respond leftists on social media have
applauded this speech called it defiant
and brave and it is at least one of
those things the former that is
um let's watch
this is an attempt to erase drag in
Tennessee
this bill will further harm trans people
who are literally just living their
lives
I need you to contact your house
representative and tell them this will
not stand tell the urge them to vote no
because if they don't this will make
public Pride illegal this year now if
you don't know we've been having a
public drag in Tennessee for over 50
years and pride began to commemorate the
events of Stonewall
back in Stonewall we weren't allowed to
do drag it was criminalized and so what
happened when the cops came in and tried
to beat us down
we picked up them bricks and sent them
packets
the original Pride was a riot
and if this year we need to remind them
that we will fight for our liberation
let them know
go quietly
I may need your help with legal things
because mama ain't quit and I'll get
arrested I don't care somebody's got to
be first we'll sue the state but
whatever happens we are queer people we
are very strong and we will rise
thank you so much
myself but that is the least southern
thing that a lady can do
so to be entirely clear this Drag Queen
is calling for violence because he won't
be able to perform stripteases in front
of children anymore that's how important
grooming is to this groomer he would
rather kill than be deprived of his
right to sexualize small children but
um why is this so important to him why
can't he just be satisfied to perform
his whole weird and depraved routine in
front of adults behind closed doors
there was no movement to Outlaw drag
until you brought children into it so
why can't you just leave them out of it
the answer is partly that they that they
get a sexual thrill apparently out of
cross-dressing and dancing for kids
um it's part of the fetish for them and
they will kill to protect their fetish
because their fetish is their whole
identity it's all they have it's all
they are
that's all they've chosen to be
the other answer is that drag shows for
kids are part of their master plan for
uh indoctrinating and desensitizing the
youngest Generations they can't convince
the kids to enjoy
this stuff but they can condition them
to accept sexual perversion as normal
and uh the sooner they're exposed to it
the easier that is to do that's a large
part of the point
third-party explanation this is
essential thing to understand if you're
trying to figure out why these people
would threaten to murder others because
uh you're not going to let them strip
for children
the other part is that is simply that
they are they are raging narcissists who
have never been told no until now
we have been a disastrously permissive
culture convinced that the worst thing
we can ever say to anyone especially in
LGBT activist is no
and uh and now they've become convinced
that they have the right to never be
told no because they've never been told
no
gender ideology and LGBT activism
um is all just sexualized narcissism
anyway they've made narcissism their
entire world view
and they're reacting as any narcissist
does when you tell him no you can't do
that you cannot do whatever you want
There are rules you will follow it
doesn't matter if you don't like it your
desires do not supersede the law whether
the laws of man or of God your desires
do not supersede either
they can't handle this news they don't
know what to do with it
keep in mind these people honestly
believe that they have the right not
just to be tolerated but to be
celebrated
I've made this observation
many times but don't take it from me
here's a trans HHS official Rachel
Levine in a resurfaced video that went
viral this week
stating this point explicitly listen
you know what I like to say is you know
in terms of diversity I mean diversity
is so powerful for any organization and
diversity in all of its different
aspects including for sexual and gender
minorities
and you know you don't want to have a
tolerant environment you know gee thanks
for tolerating me I really appreciate
that um and you know an accepting
environment is good but you really want
to work on it on a welcoming and even a
celebratory environment for diversity in
all of its aspects including for lgbtq
individuals
um and so you know Hershey approached
that
we must celebrate him he tells us long
gone are the days of leave us alone let
us have our privacy that was always a
bait and switch obviously because now
actually to leave them alone would be an
attack on them
that's an attack
it is your obligation to not leave them
alone but rather to lift them on your
shoulders like Rudy at the end of the
movie and parade them around while the
crowd cheers
this demand for celebration is again
partly a tactic but it's also a sincere
expression of their overwhelming
suffocating narcissism
for people who demand celebration and uh
and and who claim the right to do
literally anything they want up to it
including holding sex shows for toddlers
is there any wonder that they react with
such demonic Fury when we not only don't
celebrate
but actively fight against their agenda
yesterday the trans activist Aaron Reed
published a tweet uh tweet thread which
garnered 40 000 likes uh in in which he
claims that
the laws being passed in places like
Tennessee and elsewhere represent an
actual genocide against trans people
and he meant it literally even provided
the UN definition of genocide to prove
his case but but of course the
definition disproves his case but that's
not the way he sees it
it's not meant as hyperbole when these
people talk this way
they actually see it as equivalent to
genocide if anyone tells them no if any
if any limitations
are placed on the trans activist or the
LGBT activist at all
if any attempt is made to control any of
their behavior it is genocide
murdering an entire group of people and
tossing their bodies in a mass grave is
on the same moral playing field as
telling Aaron Reed that he can't strip
in front of kids or chemically castrate
uh you know a 12 year old
Nicole indeed calling Aaron Reed him as
I just did in the first place is
genocide an act of evil
indistinguishable from the Holocaust
this is what they honestly believe
and it's what happens when
self-obsession becomes identity and
identity becomes religion
and their rage only increases all the
more as they realize that this kind of
hysterical yammering along with the
threats of violence and the attempts at
the platforming and shouting bigot and
labeling and all that
as they begin to realize that this isn't
going to work anymore it did work for a
long time but it doesn't work anymore
because they're now dealing with
adversaries who cannot be manipulated or
cowed into silence that easily or at all
and that's why I will conclude here by
assuring you you Aaron Reed and you the
drag queen threatening violence and and
the rest of your ilk that we aren't even
remotely done okay this is honestly only
the beginning
we've got a lot more in store for you I
promised you a year ago that we were
going to war here and I kept that
promise I'll keep this one too
there's much more to be done that needs
to be done
and we aim to do it
so the battle continues
whether you like it or not
now let's get to our five headlines
given the dreary economic forecasts that
lie ahead you might be looking for ways
to cut back on spending Pure Talk saves
the average family over 900 a year when
they switch from Verizon at T or
T-Mobile get unlimited talk text and
plenty of data for just thirty dollars a
month that's it Pure Talk is so sure
that you're going to love your service
they're backing it up with a 100 money
back guarantee so stop paying a fortune
to Verizon a t or t or T-Mobile cut your
bill in half with pure talk their
us-based customer service team makes the
switch really easy switch over to Pure
Talk in as little as 10 minutes while
keeping your phone and your phone number
your first month is guaranteed risk-free
go to puretalk.com and enter promo code
Walsh to save 50 off your first month
that's puretalk.com promo code Walsh
puretalk is simply smarter Wireless
restrictions applies see site for
details
we have to start with this I don't know
if it's the most important story in the
country right now I mean it's not but I
but it is at least the funniest and so
you know all about Sam Britton he's the
former Biden energy official who uh like
to cross-dress and call himself they
them and was also into bestiality role
play and all kinds of other sick and
insane things that none of us needed or
wanted to know about but we do now
um and he's also the guy who got fired
after stealing luggage from uh what we
thought was uh only only two women on
two separate occasions
it stole their luggage right out of the
airport out of the baggage claim now
I told you at the time that that you
know this guy pretty clear to me
stealing the luggage he's not stealing
it because he wants the luggage right
nobody needs that much baggage
especially someone like him already who
already comes with so much baggage to
begin with but it's very clear that he
is doing this and he's targeting women
because it's all part again of the sick
twisted fetish uh he has a thing for
stealing and wearing women's clothing
that was clear to me and that brings us
to this tweet from a woman named Asia
com comes in I think we'll just call her
Asia hopefully she's okay with that uh
here's the tweet
and
um
we'll see can we pull tweet up there it
is so my name is Asia Tanzanian fashion
designer based in Houston Texas USA I
lost my bag in 2018 in the DC airport
recently I heard the news on Fox news
about Sam Britton luggage issue
surprisingly I found his images where he
wore my custom-made outfit which was in
the Lost bag in 2018.
and then you can see the uh the dated
photo of her in the dress in 2018 and
then you also can see Brenton in uh in
the exact same outfit so it's a rather
distinct outfit
um it's uh very distinct because she
made she custom made the outfit she's a
fashion designer and her luggage goes
missing in 2018 four years ago and then
Britain terms up wearing her custom
clothing you know it it's it's pretty
close to a case closed on this thing
so what this means is that there he is
and I said apparently he's also wearing
this wrong he's wearing it I think he's
wearing it backwards or something he
doesn't even know how to wear the wear
the outfit
what this means is that Brenton
the baggage bandit has been patrolling
our airports for years he's been lurking
in the baggage claim area like some kind
of uh predatory you know forced creature
on the prowl this is like when when all
the small dogs and cats in a
neighborhood start going missing and you
know that there must be a coyote in the
woods except this coyote steals women's
luggage and then parades are out in
their clothing
um so when we say
here's what makes this so uh apt is that
when we say that these men are
appropriating the female identity well
he was literally doing that right I mean
we were saying that about Sam Brenton
when he was first hired and and we were
supposed to applaud him
and I know I said many other people said
that he's making a mockery he's
appropriating Womanhood and all the rest
of it we didn't realize how literally
correct we were he's actually stealing
their clothing and putting it up
yet nobody ever connected the dots
that's what's interesting
at least we don't think they did you
know I like to imagine that there was
maybe one detective somewhere out there
who was uh at the station late one night
smoking cigarettes and drinking black
coffee and pouring through all these
missing baggage cases and then uh you
know he realized that it was all done by
one man and that there was a criminal
mastermind on the loose and he had the
bulletin board up with all the newspaper
clippings and the you know and the uh
and the lines connecting them and all
that and he realized that it was Sam
Britton the entire time and he tried to
make the arrest but the brass at the
station stopped him that's what I like
to imagine happened anyway and if it
didn't happen then someone should make a
movie where something like that does
happen
all I know
is that now
like we are seeing the beginning of a of
a new metoo movement
except that in this case it's just women
coming forward because Sam Britton stole
their baggage it's gonna be it's a whole
me too thing now
Sam Britton is the Harvey Weinstein of
cross-dressing
baggage thieves he's the uh
he's the Bill Cosby of baggage claim is
Sam Britton and I just hope that more
women have the courage to speak out
it is like it's in all seriousness it's
pretty disturbing too can you imagine
like you lose your baggage and then and
then this creep then you know this creep
turns up wearing it
um so stay tuned
more on that I I will say if you're a
woman if you're a woman who has lost
your baggage at any point in the last
decade anywhere within the continental
United States or probably or probably
anywhere else in the globe we don't know
how far this conspiracy stretches but if
you're in that category I would start
looking through
well
let me stop myself I was going to say I
would start googling images of Sam
Britton to see if you can find him
wearing your clothing but if you do that
you're going to see a lot of other
things about Sam Burton that you don't
want to see so never mind you know what
maybe it's better just not to know you
probably don't want to know and all you
could do now is
move on with your life
all right WKBN and Ohio reports former
president Donald Trump spoke to those in
East Palestine after a short stop at a
little Beaver Creek on Wednesday telling
locals you are not forgotten Trump
landed to Wednesday afternoon at the
youngston Warren Regional Airport he met
briefly with local leaders at Little
Beaver Creek before making his remarks
to the media
details of his visit had not been
released to the public in advance but
several of trump supporters were in the
area to greet him with cheers some other
supporters chanted we love you Trump at
USA Trump spoke to a small group of
local leaders First Responders and the
media at the local fire station said
he's donating thousands of bottles of
cleaning supplies and pallets of bottled
water to the area that were collected
through his Trump organizations
um and he uh you know he walked around
the town he also went to McDonald's and
bought McDonald's for all the
firefighters and First Responders there
and he as mentioned he gave a speech we
have a little bit of the of that speech
Let's listen
to the people of East Palestine and to
the nearby communities in Ohio and
Pennsylvania
we have told you loud and clear you are
not forgotten you are not forgotten we
stand with you we pray for you and we
will say with you in your fight to help
answer and the accountability that you
deserve will have that accountability
it'll all be out there very clearly
um
now while he's
giving this speech and he's in Ohio
Biden is in Ukraine
and this is the advantage that Trump has
it's one of the one of the key
differences between him and Biden
a really between him and and many in DC
if not almost everyone in DC
is that and you can see this in the
visit that he connects with normal
Americans
um he just he does and the media has
been perplexed by this for years they
don't like it they
uh they've tried all they've tried all
different kinds of methods
to sever this bond between normal
Americans and this connection between
normal Americans and and Trump
um but but really well I said that
they've tried they've tried many
different strategies really it's just
the one the one strategy which is to
yell at everybody to yell at everyone
and call you a bigot and call Trump a
bigot and that's the only strategy
they've used surprisingly that hasn't
worked
um
but he connects with normal Americans
and that has a lot to do with the fact
that he doesn't have contempt for them
the way that Biden does and the way that
Pete bootage does and all of these uh DC
swamp creatures do
and you know I made this point many
times about Trump that you you look at
he's he's seen as this uh hostile figure
that's always attacking people and
getting into fights and all the rest of
it of course that's part of his appeal
but you look at everyone that Trump has
attacked okay and it's a long list
oftentimes he's attacking in response to
being attacked but it's a long list
um
but it's almost always other politicians
people in media uh celebrities public
figures
that's like that's everyone that's the
entire list it's all people in that
world
now Biden on the other hand
and the Democrats they attack Americans
okay they attack normal people just
citizens
labeling them bigots and racists uh you
know is the justice department
infamously labeling
parents at uh PTA meetings and school
board meetings terrorists
Trump never does that
because he doesn't actually hate normal
people whereas Biden really does these
people really do
um
and it turns out that when you have
basic respect for people and you treat
them like human beings they respond in
kind
shockingly now Pete budige also showed
up he showed up today so it's a day
later he finally comes and we have one
Club I haven't watched this clip yet but
he's confronted by a reporter uh and
let's watch this sorry Pete I just have
a quick question uh the American public
doesn't seem to be very confident in
your ability to do your job will you be
resigning anytime soon I'm not here for
politics I'm here to make sure the
community can get what they need will
you apologize
for the response for the slow response
taking your time let's go in here and
get away from you nope no apology
probably one of the biggest
why did it take you an entire two and a
half
to respond to East Palestine will you
apologize to the residents of this city
uh he's not there for politics really
what are you there first of all of
course you're there for politics that's
that that's uh the only reason that
you're there I mean are you there
because they actually need you for the
cleanup
um and if they did you're three weeks
late which is why bootage showing up
three weeks late it's really the worst
possible thing especially a day after
Trump okay because you're you're coming
in a day after him
and the Optics are that you only came
because Trump came which is those are
the Optics that's also the reality he
came because Trump went and he also went
because uh because he's he's been
haranged and and uh yelled at and
finally he said fine I'll go
um
but I think that just from a pure Optics
and politics standpoint showing up three
weeks late is pretty much the worst of
all possible worlds uh yeah you're
better off not going at all if you're
going to go three weeks late you're
better just not going
because then now that's not a good
option
best option is to be there on the scene
shortly after to show that you actually
care about this and that this is on your
radar because yeah again it nobody
thinks that Pete bootage is actually
practically needed there to do anything
any more than than Trump is like Trump's
not there to help with the cleanup and
to clean up all the uh train cars that
are still laying all over the place
but
the the Practical benefit of
anyone showing up especially someone
who's currently in the government is to
send a message to the people there in
the town that you are that you care
about this that you're aware of it that
you're working on it that it's on your
priority list
and instead for three weeks the people
in that town have felt totally uh
abandoned by the federal government
because they have been
so what again what's the benefit of
showing up three weeks late everybody
knows you're only there because you have
to be
um it's it's up you can't pretend that
it was an urgent priority because it
took you three weeks
but the fact that you're going at all
now it's just it just advertises that
yeah you know it's it's low down the
list of priorities
if you're if if three weeks have passed
and no one from the buy Administration
uh has showed up then
it's a really bad situation politically
but your best option I think then is to
not go at all and then make some excuse
about how well we're not we've decided
we've decided not to do that because
that would be political Showmanship and
uh we would be getting in the way and it
wouldn't be appropriate it like make
some kind of claim like that
be total totally bogus but at least you
could go with that
um excuse
that excuse is out the window because
you did still show up
of course claiming that uh they don't
want to make it to a political theater
that that would that wouldn't work
anyway because uh Biden and Biden
officials they will show up at the scene
of tragedies if it's a tragedy if it's a
tragedy a catastrophe that they find
politically useful to them
I mean they'll send
I'll send the vice president to a
funeral
of someone that no one in the
administration remotely knew
if they think it's politically useful to
them
but they figured that this was not
politically useful I said this from the
very beginning there's some people upset
about it but it's just it's obviously
true
that this happened and uh this happened
to a small town in Ohio
these are white Working Class People for
the most part and so they just don't
rate very high they're they're by
demonstration doesn't care about them
um they're not in the base
and they figured that it's just not like
that that's white Working Class People
are exactly the kind of people that if
you're in DC if you're in the media you
you ignore and they've gotten used to
ignoring them and they figured they
could do that here
but it didn't work out that way for them
I wanted to play this clip from CNN
um CNN had this report on the problem of
there not being enough black doctors
play a little bit of this
right now fewer than six percent of
doctors in the U.S identifies black or
African-American that's despite the fact
that the community makes up 12 percent
of the country's total population and
that's raising concerns about the impact
on public health CNN Health reporter
Jacqueline Howard joins us now so
Jacqueline what is being done to rectify
this
that's the thing Biana more needs to be
done to make sure that our physician
Workforce here in the U.S reflects the
diversity seen among patients now what
has been done so far we've seen more
efforts to get stem programs in grade
schools at the medical school level
we've seen more mentorship programs
particularly for students of color but
when you look at the physician Workforce
right now active doctors at this moment
we're still seeing 5.7 percent are black
or African-American and that's compared
with us Victor said 12 percent of the
U.S population when you look at Native
Americans less than one percent of
doctors are Native American and that's
compared with up to two percent of
patients when you look at Hispanic or
Latino of Physicians 6.9 percent are
doctors compared with up to 18 percent
of the U.S population so those
differences are what's concerning here
and experts say we need to do more to
make sure our doctor Workforce reflects
the diversity seen among patients yeah
we need to do more because the research
shows and we've discussed this before
the benefits of a more diverse Workforce
often sometimes doctors will dismiss the
concerns or symptoms of a certain
demographic explain what the studies
show exactly
research shows that when we have a more
diverse physician Workforce there's more
understanding and more trust between the
patient and the doctor if the doctor has
an understanding of the patient's
cultural experiences cultural background
lived experiences especially when it
comes to racism or discrimination okay
yeah if you want to treat someone's
medical condition you need to have a you
need to have an appreciation of their
lived experience of racism right if
somebody has I don't know a brain tumor
uh well how how is a doctor going to
treat the brain tumor if he doesn't
first understand the lived experience of
racism you know you got to take that
into account
that's why if you go in and you have a
brain or any kind of medical condition
you know doctor I have diabetes and
they'll ask you well what's your lived
exp have you experienced racism tell me
about your lived experience
this is what we hear from now there's a
couple of points about this first of all
you always see the left's elitism with
these kinds of things and they're
worried about
diversity among anytime you hear a
report about a problem of there not
being enough diversity in a certain
Workforce
it's always going to be oh uh it needs
to be more diversity among doctors and
surgeons there needs to be more
diversity among uh you know Hollywood
actors
there needs to be more diversity in with
NFL head coaches right it's always these
like high paying very visible jobs the
kind of jobs that they being the elites
respect
because it because these are the elites
themselves
um but they they never do that they
never do this with working class jobs if
you've noticed
they never they never they never you
never see a report like this and they're
bringing up some you know a working
class profession and say well we need
more diversity here this needs to
reflect
the diversity of the uh of uh of of the
community
or I should say they very they very
rarely do that
and when they do
do something like that because we did
hear from Pete butterjudge a couple of
couple of weeks ago about how there's
not enough uh diversity among
construction workers
so if they do bring it up you can be
guaranteed they bring it up in a way
that's totally divorced from reality
there's already a lot of racial
diversity among construction workers but
even that it's very it's very limited
so for example
um
how many female
roofers are there like
in in what sense does the does the
roofing profession reflect the uh
demographics
of the country
certainly if you break it down along
gender lines it's not reflective at all
same for let's say trash collectors
or plumbers
definitely if you break it down along
gender lines not going to be not not
gonna not go it's not going to reflect
and all the people that are working on
roofs that Workforce does not really
reflect
uh the identities of of the people that
are living under those roots
they're not as worried about that though
are they
my second question is if you are
going into surgery let's say for for
anything
um
what do you want to know about your
doctor what's going to make you feel
feel better what's going to make you
feel more confident
is it his skin color
like what do you want to know do you do
you what what would you what do you want
to be sure of do you want to be sure
that he
um got into this position because he's
the best of the best because he got
there by Merit
right and he's he's the best qualified
based on his Merit based on his skill
based on all that his experience his
training
do you want to know that right as your
eyelids start to get Droopy from the
anesthetic do you want to have that
thought in your head that these people
they're there because they're the best
and that's it and they and they they
earn that spot and so I'm in good hands
or do you want to think wow this is a
very diverse operating room
is that going to make you feel good as
you drift away
potentially for good you know to not
wake up again
because that's what's going to happen
more and more as diversity in these
kinds of professions is prioritized over
just simply who's the best
speaking of workforces daily wire has
this report Amazon employees are Furious
as the company rolls back remote work
arrangements with some threatening to
quit and others drafting petitions in
reaction to a recent announcement that
they must report to the office at least
three times per week Amazon CEO Andy
jassy wrote in a memo to employees on
Friday that the company believes teams
tend to find ways to work through hard
and complex trade-offs faster when
they're in the same physical location
shortly after the announcement hundreds
of Amazon staffers started joining an
internal slack Channel called remote
advocacy where they were
there were more than 14 000 members of
the channel as of Tuesday nearly 80 of
the workers the channel claim that they
would start to look for another job
because of the new policy so if they had
to actually go to work physically then
they would look for another job because
this is a deep uh this is a you know
this is an affront against them
one disgruntlet employee wrote this is
going to be absolute chaos and make
everyone's work distracted for probably
a quarter maybe longer it's hard to be
productive with so much uncertainty
injected into our lives shift towards
more traditional work Arrangements
however comes as Amazon seeks to
downsize amid macroeconomic tumult and a
decline in consumer demand that followed
the lockdown-induced recession
Amazon dismissed some 18 000 employees
over the past several months
um employees in the slack Channel
nevertheless drafted petitions against
the return to the office to office
policy says we the undersigned
amazonians are responding by petitioning
for the right to choose where to work
including remote locations
the petition included survey data which
found 56 of Amazon employees desire
monthly sync UPS in the office while 31
want to work in the office one or two
days per week
you know there's um when I when I hear
about these controversies about you know
this still these companies and um
corporations that have not gotten back
to working in the office and so there's
these employees that uh think they have
a right to stay home and work from home
it reminds me of this of a Louis C.K bit
where he talks about his first
experience years ago using Wi-Fi on a
plane and the Wi-Fi goes out and a guy
behind him gets mad at the Wi-Fi is down
and it's like because it's a brand new
thing that they just had it goes away
and the guy's mad about it
and Louise Decay points out that like
how how quickly does the world owe you
something that you didn't even know
existed until 10 seconds ago and I think
that remote work is a is a little bit
like that where people feel entitled to
work and earn a living without ever even
leaving their beds and that's that's
that's an option that didn't exist until
10 seconds ago now you can point out all
you want is people often do in this
conversation that the the nine to five
job uh you know leaving your house and
driving across town or to another town
or maybe going to another state in some
cases to go work in a different building
for for eight to ten hours a day and
coming home you can point out that that
is also a comparatively new phenomenon
that's an invention of the Industrial
Age and that's certainly the case
sure and there was a time when family
units
um in effect you know like they they
didn't they didn't have to leave their
Homestead or their home in order to work
but
if you go back before the invention in
they weren't just sitting around on
their couch all day okay they had to
leave they were still doing work
uh you know go out and work in the
fields or something
so the idea that you should be able to
earn a living
without ever even leaving your bedroom
that you should be able to do that that
you have like the right to do that
that is as modern as it possibly can get
and to me it's pretty clear that I mean
does it does it
we could talk about whether it helps
you know is it is it good for your job
is it good for the company you work for
when everyone lives all scattered
throughout the country and they're not
physically working together is that good
for you know does it make you work
better does it does it improve the the
kind of work that you're doing is it
better for uh for especially things like
creative collaboration I think obviously
not
but then there's also the question of is
this good is it just is it a good thing
for the country
you know to take it to isolate people
even more than they already are and to
take yet another
um
another
piece of like human to human in-person
interaction and to take that away and to
replace it with screens is that is that
actually is that a good development for
society it's hard to imagine how anyone
could argue that it is
so
get back to work if you work for Amazon
that's what I'm trying to say let's get
to the comment section
[Music]
well in case you hadn't uh happened upon
it yet we have new SBG swag available
over at dailywire.com shop we hear the
daily wire understand the vortex of evil
can be a bit chilly at times so we're
giving you Solutions pledging fealty to
the Gang has never been Cozier with the
new sweet baby gang script hoodie
script honey what does that mean the
Wardrobe staple of a gray hoodie meets
the moral obligation of donning the
appropriate Garb of a dedicated sweet
baby two birds one very comfortable
Stone but why stop there the SPG blanket
is here to make your dream of repping
the gang from the comfort of your own
home a reality every gang member needs
to have a cozy blanket that's what I
always say it's what they say out on the
streets as well take it on the road for
sporting events or just to keep in your
car I wish I had one of these in the
early days of my podcast got quite
chilly when I was homeless in my car
sweet babies in the merch Department
churn out new products for the swag
Shack all the time so be sure to check
back routinely for the next best way to
reaffirm your commitment to the gang but
you got to go to dailywire.com shop
today
Terence says Matt I've never felt as
much Brotherhood with a celebrity as I
do with you keep keep it up we're
standing behind you I hate to tell you
this uh Terence but you still don't have
Brotherhood with a celebrity because I'm
not one but I appreciate you all the
same uh Sarah sketchable says Matt's new
strategy to fill 10 of his Daily Show
time with clips from the day before's
show well hey you look if it works it
works if they if they if that content is
presented to me then uh then that's
that's what I'll do it's not just
filling time
um you know maybe it's a little bit like
my when I was in Middle School in my
book report strategy was to like you
know it had to be two pages a page and a
half of the book report was just
summarizing the book
before you make any point about it
um
guy says I completely agree that Matt is
telling the truth when he said his best
jeopardy games are the ones when no one
is there he started off shouting alone
in his car to barely anyone and now here
he is
yeah I think that's probably a lot for a
lot of people it's just the way it goes
you know your best playing Jeopardy when
you're alone in your living room it's
also when I when I this is this is
legitimately when I catch the biggest
fish also is when I'm fishing alone and
no one else is around that's when I
catch the uh it's also it's when I
when I'm fishing alone and um and my
phone is dead so I can't take a picture
of the fish that's when I catch the
really big ones it's just how it goes
weed
just the username is weed uh wasn't Matt
saying a few years ago that a national
divorce is necessary when that woman
comedian Sarah Silverman I guess said
something similar in a podcast that Matt
agreed if I recall correctly
yeah that's why I said I've been along
with other mostly conservatives I think
although Sarah Silverman isn't but talk
about this National divorce idea for for
years
um and I've always said that I
understand you know I understand the
argument for it in theory I've given and
I've explained that position
um and there was probably a time when I
when I would have what I would have said
yeah let's let's actually try to do it
my my thinking on it has changed though
um for all the reasons that I gave
yesterday
you know to beginning with the fact that
it's just not possible you know and
especially in recent years I've tried to
like we can talk in theory about things
we can talk in the abstract what would
be the best thing like what's the most
ideal uh if we could do anything we
wanted what would it be there's value in
having conversations like that but I I
do like to focus more now on what is
practical and what is actual and what
can really happen
and the national divorce
for Geographic reasons to begin with
can't happen so that's one thing that's
changed my thinking on it and then also
what I said yesterday about how you know
I I just it is it's hard for me to see
that as anything but surrender you're
giving up what half the country to these
people I'm not going to do that I refuse
to do it
um
so
that's why my thinking has changed
um
MK Ultra says my theory is that Gloria
Johnson let fetterman write that tweet
for her see this is proof by the way
that I am nice because uh we had that
Gloria Johnson incoherent tweet up
yesterday and uh and and people say I'm
not a nice guy I almost made a fetterman
joke but I but I didn't because I wanted
to be nice so I switched to uh Camilla
Harris instead so I was gonna mock one
person I mocked somebody else instead
that's what counts as niceness for me
Cali says you're so right about game
shows being such a gamble with a very
real possibility of being a viral Fail
video for the rest of forever my family
was actually on Family Feud and my
brother is the chicken noodle soup guy
on there basically the prompt from Steve
Harvey was what kind of suit is not
appropriate to wear to the office my
brother had a brain fart and said
chicken noodle he's now a firefighter in
every station he's ever worked at uh has
known he's has known him as soup and
even has a Campbell Soup sticker on his
helmet when they gear up the best part
about it is that he was convinced that
my dad was going to be the one
embarrassing the family with some kind
of fluke he even said Dad pay attention
to the prompts I don't want to end up as
some YouTube fail now every Family Feud
puts out a best best fails of the series
video and he always makes the top five
just desserts for giving our dad a hard
time if you ask me well
absolutely I'm sorry to hear about your
brother's humiliation
but in order to appreciate how sorry we
should really feel for him because again
I am a nice person and very empathetic
and I want to know just how sorry should
I be and I also I think for the sake of
being able to pray for him in this
difficult time this difficult time which
is the rest of his life I suppose I
think we need to watch that video
because I'm not even familiar with this
um but here is the video that you're
referring to
guys here we go point value is a double
we
have answers on the board name a kind of
suit that's not appropriate for the
office
chicken noodle
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't wear no damn chicken noodle
soup in here
birthday birthday
thank you
[Applause]
that's tough I'm sorry for your brother
um
that's a tough one you know on one hand
on one hand it's not as bad
like it's not as bad as the as the woman
yesterday on Wheel of Fortune who had
the one letter to guess and it was fresh
fruit and she only needed the S and she
said g to spell frag fruit like it's not
as bad as that because it's he did
mishear the question and so I can
understand that you know suit sounds
like soup
but then why would they be asking about
inappropriate soups for the office are
there is what
and are there office soups and then um
home soups
and if there is an inappropriate Soup
for the office why would it be chicken
noodle I mean that would be the that
would be the most appropriate Soup for
the office now when I think about what's
an inappropriate Soup for the office
um I guess I would what comes to mind
are soups that are especially pungent in
odor uh so you wouldn't want to you know
heat those up in the break room
microwave because they so then it's like
french onion okay so that if you hear it
that way then why wouldn't your answer
be French onion because that's obviously
the kind of soup that you don't want to
bring to the office it smells bad it
smells too much like onions and you're
gonna smell like uh but the chicken
noodle soup that's the the most Bland
inoffensive soup there is and also if it
makes if you make the the break room
smell like chicken noodle soup who who
would complain about that smells like
Grandma's home cooking in the in the
office what's wrong with that
foreign
so I want to say that that was not
really an enormously stupid answer
because it was really just he misheard
him but even based on what he thought
the question was it still comes down to
being a stupid answer
so we will continue to pray for your
brother
snow Seeker the left hates our country
and wants to rewrite history they
villainize Our Heroes they emit key
details from the historical record like
the fact that on Christmas night 1776
George Washington only crossed the
Delaware River in a sneak attack against
the British forces after shaving with a
Jeremy's razors few people know that sad
reflection of our great nation going
woke our history being erased but like
Washington before us you can fight back
against woke tyranny simply by picking
up a magnificent Jeremy's razors during
our 30 off President's Day Sale it's
time we celebrate history not cancel it
so unless you want our founding fathers
renamed to our founding non-birthing
parents you got to go to
jeremy'sraisers.com today and get 30 off
any razor that's jeremy'srazors.com
today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well it's been about four weeks since
the last one so we're right on schedule
for another left-wing race Hustler
activist to be revealed as a secret
white woman pretending to be a person of
color and right on cue Raquel Avida
Saraswati whose real name is apparently
Rachel Elizabeth Seidel has stepped up
to the plate the post-millennial has the
story a prominent Muslim activist who
claimed for years to be a woman of color
has been outed as white as the driven
snow by none other than her own mother
Raquel La Vida Saraswati born Rachel
Elizabeth Seidel to parents of German
British and Italian heritage
fooled people into thinking she was
South Asian Arab and Latina she even
managed to use her fake ethnic
credentials to score a role as the chief
Equity inclusion and culture officer at
the American friends service committee a
progressive Quaker organization that
fights for equality and social justice
according to the intercept the 39 year
old had converted to Islam in high
school and has been masquerading as
non-white for nearly two decades
I don't know why she's doing what she's
doing sir swati's mother Carol Perrone
said she's chosen to live a lie and I
find that very very sad I'm as white as
the driven snow and so is she
um Oscar Pierre Castro one of the human
resources officers who took part in
saraswati's hiring claimed that she had
touched all the points by presenting as
a queer Muslim multi-ethnic woman I
definitely feel conned I feel deceived
he said following the revelations that
her identity was a lie
now Rachel hasn't said much publicly as
her story has fallen apart on Saturday
she tried to stall for time tweeting I
assure people that as soon as I'm
capable I will provide answers to the
recent discussion and attack on me I
understand all the reactions you're
having I'm currently taking the time to
get to where I can answer in a way that
is most helpful and thorough
yeah she needs to go on another journey
of self-discovery to find out why she
was pretending to belong to five
different victim groups uh she needs she
needs you know to get to a place where
she can really see the answers to those
questions
well I can help her with that
um Rachel you did it because you saw it
as the easiest way to accrue Social
Capital it's as simple as that like so
many other people in our culture today
you are not confident in your abilities
to succeed based on your own Merit you
don't think you have anything of value
to offer the world so instead you tried
to ride a wave of pity and
self-victimization you hope to achieve
success and gain esteem through
manipulating society's victimhood
algorithm you engaged in the societal
equivalent of Click bait you presented
yourself as a victim because you know
that these days victimhood is power and
that's the answer okay you're welcome
this kind of story is is barely
interesting anymore Rachel dolezal made
the mistake of being slightly out ahead
of the trend and so her deception was
Major news for days on end and even to
this day she remains Infamous like a
household name so
um but so many have come after her
that now it's become routine we all we
all already assume that at this point
probably half of the black activists in
the country are actually white women
like we just assume that and each time a
new one is revealed it barely leaves a
blip on the radar screen
but there was another somewhat similar
though different in keyways story this
week that I find uh much more
fascinating
and you know we know how it plays out
when a white activist pretends to be
black but what happens when a black
activist
finds out that she's white or at least
much wider than she thought she was or
ever hoped to be
that brings us to Angela Davis who is a
Marxist a former black panther a long
time race Hustler who in recent years
has popped up doing things like leading
the women's March calling for the
abolition of the police and of the
prison system
well she appeared this week on the PBS
show Finding Your Roots in which
prominent people are presented the
results of DNA tests tracing their
ancestry back uh generations to see you
know where they come from
Angela Davis was not exactly thrilled
with her results listen
any idea what you're looking at
that is a list of the passengers on the
Mayflower
no I can't believe this no my ancestors
did not come here on the Mayflower your
ancestors came on the Mayflower no no no
you are descended from one of the 101
people who sailed on the Mayflower
oh
that's a little bit too much
to deal with right now did you ever in
your wildest dreams think that you may
have descended from people who laid
never the foundation never for this
country never never
and just like that the oppressed becomes
the oppressor the colonized becomes the
colonizer now for a normal person with a
healthy mindset it'd be it'd be an
exciting and interesting thing to find
out that your lineage goes back directly
to the Mayflower I'm pretty certain that
mine doesn't but if it did I'd be
incredibly proud to know that I'm
descended from uh people who as the host
says laid the foundation I would also be
proud that my roots in this country go
that deep
uh that would be a that'd be a wonderful
thing to find out Angela Davis on the
other hand reacts you reacts like a
deadbeat dad on a daytime talk show
finding out that uh he really is the
father like she's that that's how upset
she is
actually gets better because she's
descended from a pilgrim on her father's
side
what about her mother's side
well as it turns out her maternal line
leads directly back to a man named
Stephen Darden who is a white man a
revolutionary war soldier who moved to
Georgia after the war and became a slave
owner
so Angela Davis has deep roots in this
country indeed
um that's slave owner and a pilgrim
finding out all this information Davis
said quote I always imagine my ancestors
as the people who were enslaved
yes well we know you did Angela this has
been to say to say the very least a very
interesting Black History Month for
Angela Davis as it would seem that her
own
black history is far less black than she
expected and the only question now is
you know I guess who does she make her
reparations check out to herself perhaps
I don't know
now of course in reality
the details of Angela's family tree are
nothing but interesting historical
tidbits as I said anybody with a healthy
perspective on things and who finds out
that their lineage traces back to the
Revolutionary War and then all the way
back to the Mayflower would be
fascinated and and thrilled and filled
with patriotic Pride
healthy person is not upset to find out
their ancestors were quote unquote
colonizers especially as there's nothing
inherently wrong and often quite a lot
that's heroic and virtuous about you
know starting colonies especially back
hundreds of years ago
so I'm not saying the Angela Davis
actually has anything to be ashamed of
or to apologize for but the trouble is
that Angela Davis according to her own
ideology says that Angela Davis has much
to be ashamed of and to apologize for
as a left-wing racial activist she's a
proponent of the idea that oppression
trickles down through the generation she
believes that the early settlers of this
country were land thieves and evil
colonizers she believes that people who
descend from slave owners carry that
guilt with them this is what her
worldview professes and now it's turned
against her
and and we would have to be soulless to
not enjoy the spectacle at least a
little bit but perhaps there's a lesson
to be learned here though a lesson that
Angela Davis and her left-wing Ray
hustling ilk need to learn uh the rest
of us already know it but this is this
is a news to them
and the lesson
is that the historical oppression math
is much more complicated than they want
it to be
Angela Davis descends from slave owners
and from people that she would call
colonizers
many white people in this country
descend directly from poor European
immigrants who came here a century or
more after her great great great great
grandfather bought his first slave
so who's more historically oppressed in
that case
if we start handing out reparations
should people who descend from early
20th century immigrants pay reparations
to a woman who descends from a slave
owner and a pilgrim
see the picture is rather cloudy much
more cloudy than these people want to
admit
that's because obviously everyone
descends from the oppressors everyone
descends from the oppressed
everyone has pain and suffering and
blood and sweat and tears and heroism
and guilt and sin and virtue and failure
and achievement all throughout their
lineage
if these things can be passed down in
the bloodstream then it's it's very
difficult to tally up the points at the
end and figure out who's ahead
even people who actually descend from
slaves may also descend from slave
owners and slave traders in Africa if
you go back another generation or two
the world was a brutal place and still
is
and it's always been funny to me that
the people who love to find moral gray
areas everywhere constantly are talking
about oh it's a gray area you know we
can't engage in black and white thinking
well somehow they can't see the gray
areas here where there actually is a
gray area where it's just nothing but a
giant gray area when deciding when
deciding the good guys of history or the
bad guys the oppressed the oppressor all
you find
if you take if you look through a wide
enough lens is a whole lot of gray and
this is not a problem unless you're
looking to stand on your ancestors
graves in order to claim victim points
today then it becomes a problem
that's what Angela Davis and her fellow
race Hustlers have always done and
that's why
Angela Davis
the granddaughter of slave owners and
colonizers is today canceled
and I'll do it for this portion of shows
and move over to the members block if
you're not a member yet become a member
and use code Walsh at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign